it's a bullying Capcom exclusive well
it's a cool grabbing rap man you gotta
do that free get out of here well you
know that's my profession that's my job
I appreciate that a lot of rappers come
in and they they don't want to rap or
they'll have their record rep sacred
don't come in beforehand nobodyís Hey
look don't ask him to rap is his throat
hurts right hey good it's big in a
rapping man like what's this beat this
on right now new God flows you wanna go
in over this I'm feeling this all right
we're gonna do it man I got d1 in the
building hit him on Twitter what's your
Twitter you wanna use it give me the
number one music hit me up man I'll let
this guy is about to kill this man's
power 98.3 Ready Set Radio let's do it
oh oh let's go in look I went from last
to first and did it with style I'm from
where shoppers burst in Simmons go pow I
call a spade a spade and a fraud or
almost foking really fakes for my faith
in God I got some haters for sale if
you're trying to purchase depreciate you
to the point they visit you're worthless
but I appreciate them cuz you know
they're making me flourish why you mad
cuz your girlfriend singing me chorus
I'm a hard evl frigid chick in a room
but you couldn't even tell Riley cuz I
Drive an H Oh
it ain't cold got a half a million miles
ma'am I whipped and went goal I'm on the
road we on the road another show three
in a row my pending yeah froze by true
my rhymes cold that's how I'm living dog
that's how I'm rockin bro
you stupid fool you saw your soda be
popular you saw your soda be popular you
stupid fool up nothing I come from a
city where growing up is mad tough and
it ain't no cat servo we said put your
hands up New Orleans stand up we are are
we man up never had bad luck I just
never had much Oh you rich and what you
can keep your cash brother or open in
your heart that's all that I ask for
only real people feeling so if I get
gassed up my supporters cool me down I
call them fans brother ever hopefully I
could win some awards just so I can
stand up here and go flying New Orleans
making noise every first thank the Lord
a family they're my boys I'm chosen for
this position this is not my choice and
my voice is an instrument but we are all
one band and yeah I'm cool but only put
your faith in one man since I she love
me sometimes she love me now but it's
all I am a soul I know man this music is
all I got
yo what
anyone I'm speechless man shell is
everybody driving huh hey yeah set it
yeah we gotta cut it off keep going go
again go again
get up la la la la la this ribs all
right here this is for the couches that
I crashed on all the floors that I slept
on tissues that I wept on the cars that
I slept in the kids that I left when I
quit teaching to try reaching my pukes
in the streets and God if I opposed a
rep please let me know but if I'm posed
to rap God please let me blow I'm
thinking revolution never where I
stopped they said I can't change the
world I'm thinking why not
we're raising girls to Queens we're
raising boys to men I spit that common
sense that's words aligning Lynn some
say that is prophetic some say that is
poetic I'm building the connected but
locally respected somebody dying as I
wrap this verse and let you know this
life short like the Catholic Church I'm
grinding for the cause now for the cause
but even when I get the cause they cause
the never pulse
yo ready for the cause my foot a card
bang
use a monster man mad at that man now
that's a d1 my dude eros
that was bananas home yeah Arizona love
make sure you get the focused a man who
is this guy who is this guy a rapping is
d12 one-man army from the waters make
sure you get the focused tape right nice